it's like it feels like white's starting
to get in some trouble here
because now that knight is tied down
to the h-pawn in some ways i guess and
this a-pawn these queenside ponds are
still coming like there's nothing that's
really
that night's sort of getting far away
from the action in some ways
you know she's she's up against the the
some of the best obviously so we've been
rooting for her hopefully to
not rooting against anyone but
certainly hoping she gets some
some points on the board
so
yeah i hope she beats um
nepo specifically i'm not sure why i'm
rooting for that result but i think they
already played so much
as you say is there some do you have
some grudge mad you have some uh did you
did you wager on this before today no
nothing in
particular um there no time to mate
because
magnus has been annoyingly giving checks
this whole time so bishop e4 check
bishop e5 g3
and now at some point i believe he's
going to cover the mate with like bishop
uh oh sorry sorry now there's no more
mate because the king has an escape
square so no no no okay it looks like
han's resigned yeah that's gg
yeah very unfortunate i mean he he is
definitely
more than okay there that's